do you think
the weight behind the word nazi racist
bigot has lost its weight because
everybody's thrown around nowadays where
it no longer has the weight at once had
or do you think it still carries weight
yeah it it it should
it should carry far less weight and and
i i mean especially today where
you know you can get called that for
anything for any reason
and this is something that i i've tried
to tell liberal
friends of mine for years right you call
somebody a fascist
right well watch out because when the
real mccoy comes along someday no one's
going to believe you when you call out
somebody who's really a fascist
you call everyone a racist no one's
going to believe you when someone comes
along who's genuinely a racist
and by the way i say this to
conservative friends a lot
just because someone's a liberal you
disagree with him don't call him akami
right you know you know communism is a
very
unique specific thing you know you might
call him a radical lefty right call him
a lefty crazy
call him a loony left something like
that but but you know don't fling that
kind of language around
both sides need to be more careful and
thoughtful about their rhetoric
and their names but the left in
particular i mean you know i've had
people
people say to me i've heard this i've
heard this more in the past six months
or so
especially after the trump
administration right um
that people just simply no longer take
that charge of
racist seriously because the left has
absolutely so abused it and annihilated
it
that it doesn't carry the weight that
that that it should
yeah it's funny you say that i had uh
david horowitz on you know david
horowitz
who was a pretty well known grove city
college yeah a couple of years ago
amazing yep yeah i had him on and he
kept saying everybody the democrats are
communists i said you can't say that he
says i'm telling you they're coming out
i don't believe every one of them is
because we're losing them he says
everybody keeps saying so anyways we had
a nice interesting conversation together
on
because i agree with you on the fact
that we're also labeling everybody not
everybody's in the same box
second question for you on this side
here so for me
as a person that's a business owner i'm
an entrepreneur i have to always get to
the bottom of the issue because
you can fix issues on the surface it
keeps reappearing
but you got to get to the bottom of the
route to figure out exactly why this
issue keeps surfacing so you said this
has been going on for a while
okay so i'm 42 okay i came to the states
november 20
28 1990 which means i don't know
pre november 29 matter of fact i didn't
even follow politics for quite some time
so go even past that right if this has
been going on
forever has this been going on forever
as in since
biblical times pre-biblical times
meaning are we always going to go
through this 20 years from now 40 years
from now 80 years from now 300 years
from now 800 years 1 thousand years from
now because it's a cyclical cycle of
one person makes the money the other one
says it's unfair he feels envious let's
take the money and give it to everybody
else so
it's a constant pendulum that will go
through and it's never ending
or is it any way different today
than it was before 40 years from now 80
years from now 100 years from now 500
years from now
500 years ago well i i do think it's
worse now
than ever and it's getting worse but
like for example yesterday in class i
teach a course on marxism
we were talking about the hollywood ten
and
every single member of the hollywood ten
was was a was a member of communist
party usa
we had their five-digit communist party
usa numbers
in fact they were presented before the
members of uh
hollywood 10 when they were speaking to
congress october and november 1947
house committee and un-american
activities john howard lawson who was
one of the worst of them
when he was called in to testify after
telling all of his liberal friends in
hollywood
humphrey bogart lauren bacall um you
know
danny kaye gene kelly some
judy garland some of these wonderful
actors and actresses who by the way were
liberals right they were not communists
right they were progressives
but he was telling them i'm not a
communist these right-wing fanatics in
washington d
i yeah i'm not that i'm not yeah i'm
like you so he got up there and he
testified before congress and they said
mr lawson
here on this billboard here on this um
poster board
here's your communist party usa number
here's all the checks you wrote out to
communist party usa
here's your dues here's your application
and and john howard lawson patrick you
know i did he kind of stood in his seat
and he yelled
nazis right this is like
this is like the reichstag fire in
berlin
he just started calling him names right
he just started calling
and these guys all that they had done
was exposed them
as being a communist so what did he do
he called them all these names probably
called him a homophobe if that name had
existed back then right
so so you see this among the the kind of
extreme left for quite some time
i'll go back a little further karl marx
um
i spent a lot of time on this in in the
devil and karl marx
uh marx and these marxists like to say
that business people
are are capitalists who are obsessed
with money
right um no guys like marx
and marxists and communists they're the
ones who are obsessed with money
that's all that these guys think about
you you read some of marx's anti-semitic
statements
they are chilling right it says things
like
what is the worldly god of the jew money
what does the jew worship haggling and i
read that and i think to myself
no carl you're the one that worships
money right
you're the one that's obsessed with
money you're so obsessed with money that
you can't even think enough about your
own money
you think about everybody else's money
right you
you want you want a central government
to come in and forcibly take it and
redistribute it
so it's funny oftentimes when they're
yelling at you
haters screaming at them and you're
thinking i'm not hating at all i've got
a smile on my face
while you're talking to me they're
projecting on to you what they're really
feeling
and they do that a lot with um with with
money and attacking people with
property and attacking capitalists a lot
of this is a sort of self-projection
it's almost psychological by some of
these individuals so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
[Music]
you